the united states economy is
experiencing a 40-year high in inflation
the last reading came in at 8.6 in cpi
and many people believe the next print
is going to be even higher but one thing
that's very interesting is that the u.s
dollar although it is experiencing that
40-year high in inflation it is
strengthening against many other
currencies in fact the u.s dollar has
hit a 20-year high on a relative basket
of other fiat currencies we can see just
yesterday that the euro has effectively
reached parity with the us dollar this
is the first time this has happened in
20 years so yes the us dollar is
experiencing all sorts of pain and
people who hold that dollar in the u.s
economy aren't exactly better off
but the us dollar is doing better than
many other fiat currencies and so you
see the dollar strengthening against
that basket and what it means is that
those other currencies are doing even
worse to see the euro fall and 1 euro is
one dollar means that the dollar has
strengthened and the euro has weakened
there's all sorts of different
investments and various business
decisions that are being made a weak
euro means that there's lots of
opportunity for people to capitalize on
but a strong dollar
also has many other opportunities that
investors and business owners will
continue to try to exploit
make sure that you're paying attention
to the macro environment the fed appears
to be in control they continue to talk
about destroying demand to try to get
inflation down but at the same time that
they're dealing with that historically
high inflation we're watching the dollar
strengthen and someone like brent
johnson who has put forward the
milkshake theory is looking pretty smart
right now
the milkshake theory is the idea that
although central banks around the world
are going to continue to pursue loose
monetary policy and that various elected
officials will also inject fiscal policy
into their economies in a variety of
different ways the us dollar is still
the strongest most sought after fiat
currency in the world
and it will strengthen against a basket
of other fiat currencies it's exactly
what we're seeing play out right now
ultimately fiat currencies they all have
an unlimited supply and they continue to
be debased at historic pace
but there is a race which countries and
which central banks will strengthen
their currencies faster than others
and which countries and central banks
will weaken their currencies faster than
all the others there's a lot of movement
right now in the currency world the
ground is shifting beneath us
and most people especially the bitcoin
community they're sitting back and
they're watching all this play out and
they're saying there's got to be a
better way